hey was geht ab und bekommen bei einem
neuen video hier mal wieder auf meinem
channel und zwar irgendwie ich in
letzter zeit mal wieder so ein ganz
bisschen und facebook unterwegs und da
sind mir auch um ganz park kleine
witzige story von justin bieber ins auge
gefallen und darüber gedacht komm mach
doch direkt mal wieder ein video darüber
was heißt mal wieder habe er nie auf
jeden fall fällt er glaube ich manchmal
ein bisschen öfter auf und da will ich
heute mal so ein bisschen für euch
zusammen passen weil da auch viele
dachten das ist jetzt mein gefängnis und
was weis ich war im endeffekt auch aber
bleibt einmal dran dann versteht ihr das
alles und ich wünsche mir natürlich viel
spaß
vorweg wenn ich aber noch sagen dass sie
eigentlich nichts gegen justin bieber
hat seine musik jetzt war nicht ganz so
oft höre ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht
so manchmal vielleicht nie da so auf
jeden fall habe ich nichts sehen ich bin
eigentlich sogar cool ich wollte ihn
sogar auf instagram und im jahr
ansonsten noch was an den ganzen
geschichten wahr ist und was nicht das
stelle ich jetzt meine frage auf jeden
fall habe ich schon diese ganzen total
idiotischen beiträge oft davon den
unrealistischen internet seiten unseres
planeten schon so ein bisschen
herausgefiltert also die erfahrt ihr gar
nicht was da alle für eine scheiße
geschrieben wird im netz und ich würde
sagen wir fahren jetzt mal wirklich an
also das ganze spielte sich eigentlich
so in miami habe ich weil die wunderbar
oder so keine ahnung ob mir eigentlich
nicht auf jeden fall ist er das erste
mal auffällig geworden als er in ein
striplokal oder strip club gegangen ist
will stripclub gegangen ist und da
irgendwie mehrere zehntausend euro
investiert frag mich nicht wofür ich
weiß ich wie man in strip club gehen
kann unter mehrere zehntausend euro
loswerden kann aber erst geschafft also
auf jeden fall schon mal respekt dafür
und das war dann so der grund warum die
polizei halt irgendwie so das erste mal
auf ihn aufmerksam wurde oder das erste
mal wieder auf jeden fall ja kurz darauf
ist er dann erneut auffällig geworden in
dem er sich übrigens coole aktion auf
jeden fall in dem er sich einfach mal so
gedacht hat ach komm ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal ein paar eier und klatschte
gegen die hauswand von meinem nachbarn
da frage ich mich auch so wer wunder
eigentlich da muss man bestimmt keine
ahnung lady gaga robbie williams keine
ahnung hat einfach mal angenommen und
die gegen die villen von den geklatscht
oder wat auf jeden fall hat dass sein
nachbar beziehungsweise seine nachbarin
irgendwie logischerweise mitbekommen und
dann erstmal die polizei alarmiert die
dann auch am nächsten tag bei justin
bieber vor der haustür stand irgendwie
nach hausdurchsuchungen dabei noch
gemacht hat und
irgendwie auch ein paar gramm drogen
gestoßen ist scheiße gelaufen
ob die drogen jetzt ihm gehören oder
nicht das kann ich natürlich auch nicht
sagen ich glaube das weiß keiner so
richtig auf jeden fall steht aber unter
verdacht dass es eventuell seine drogen
sein können als wäre das nicht schon
genug ist er dann irgendwie am nächsten
tag oder in der nächsten woche ich weiß
nicht ganz genau schon wieder auffällig
geworden dann ist auch noch gar nicht so
lange her ich glaube das war von oder
das war in der nacht von mittwoch auf
donnerstag also letzten mittwoch auf
donnerstag da hat es ja einfach mal so
gedacht ach komm ich mit mir jetzt mal
so ein lamborghini also das war nicht
sein verstehe auch nicht ganz so warum
auf jeden fall hat er sich dann seinen
lamborghini halb gemietet und dort an so
gedacht ach komm ich mache jetzt mal
gegen meinen kumpel des irgend so ein
rapper dessen name ich irgendwie noch
nie gehört haben sondern illegale
straßenrennen also das müsst ihr so
vorstellen wie er mal irgendwo so eine
strecke ausgesucht dann haben zwei autos
sei die strecke ab werden wir haben
irgendwie nachts um zwei uhr morgens
seinen straßen ende straßenrennen
illegale straßenrennen veranstaltet wer
ist jetzt der straße gewesen wo die
autos mit 150 km/h herr brettern dann
hätte wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie
keiner was gemerkt allerdings haben sie
sich da so eine straße ausgesucht wurden
normalerweise die autos 40 km/h fahren
und das ist ja klar dass die nachbarn
ein irgendwie darauf auffällig gemacht
werden wenn er plötzlich so zweiten
lamborghini und ferrari mit 300 lang
fahren die anwohner dieser straße haben
dann logischerweise schon wieder oder
wieder mal die polizei alarmiert oder
wieder mal wegen das wie war die polizei
alarmiert die dann auch da
vorbeigeschaut hat und um vier uhr
morgens statt ihn wie besoffen auf dem
beifahrersitz eines geliehenen
lamborghini finden beziehungsweise
festnehmen konnte keine ahnung ich frage
mich was geht denn so prominenten vor
oder in so nicht prominenten sondern
mega prominenten darauf folgte das er
ich betone eigentlich ins gefängnis
hätte kommen müssen was auch irgendwie
halt facebook geglaubt hat mit diesem
video kann ich euch aber eigentlich was
das angeht ziemlich beruhigen also
indirekt was heißt indirekt im gefängnis
war ja eigentlich schon allerdings nur
für zwölf stunden weil er dann irgendwie
auf kaution von 1800 euro
umgerechnet nach zwölf stunden am
donnerstagabend wieder verlassen konnte
wenn man da jetzt im endeffekt war
darüber nachdenkt dann hört sich das
alles irgendwie schon ziemlich krass an
finde ich und ich bin denke dabei auf
jeden fall wenn er jetzt so weiter macht
wo das hinführen sollte in ein oder zwei
jahren naja hauptsache endet nicht so
wie irgendwelche anderen stars die sich
da ihnen dach besoffen haben und danach
drei wochen gestorben sind so leute und
jetzt stehe ich hier auch leider schon
wieder am ende dieses videos und ja wenn
solche gefeiert dann gebt natürlich
einfach mal daumen nach oben und mich
willst natürlich auch sehr interessieren
was eure meinung zu diesem ganzen thema
ist findet ihr es auch so irgendwie
bescheuert oder auch irgendwie geil wie
ich ja lasst einfach mal eure
kreativität freien lauf und schreibt was
heißt kreativität last einer eurer
meinung freien lauf und schreibt diese
und in die kommentare und toyo wenn ihr
nichts mehr verpassen wollt dann
abonniert doch einfach diesen kanal
checkt auch unbedingt man die video
beschreibung für instagram und andere
social networks ab und hier unten rechts
und links millionen links und rechts
geht's weiter mit meinen letzten beiden
videos auch unbedingt mal abchecken und
wir sehen uns dann nächste woche wieder
und ich wünsche euch natürlich auch ein
schönes wochenende dann haut rein und
wir sehen uns